welcome everyone this screencast is an
overview of assignment 3 and the
associated bake off our topic is
compositional generalization this is a
favorite topic of mine this is our
attempt to really probe deeply to see
whether models have learned to
systematically interpret natural
language
the starting point for the work is the
cogs paper and the associated Benchmark
from Kim and lindsen we're actually
going to work with a modification of
cogs that we call recogns this is recent
work that we released and it simply
attempts to address some of the
limitations that we perceive in the
original cogs Benchmark while
nonetheless adopting the core insights
and core agenda that Cog set
the recog's task is fundamentally a
semantic parsing task the inputs are
simple sentences and the outputs are
logical forms like this so here in this
example the input is a rose was helped
by a dog and you can see that the output
is a sort of event description as a
logical form we have an indefinite arose
an indefinite dog we have a helping
event the theme of that helping event is
the rose and the agent of that helping
event is the dog here is a similar
example the Sailor dusted a boy and it
has an output that looks like this the
new element here is that we have a
definite description in the input and
that's marked by a star in the output
this is like the Sailor here
you can probably see that the cogs and
recog sentences tend to be somewhat
unusual this is a synthetic Benchmark
they were automatically generated from a
context-free grammar and so their actual
meanings are sort of unusual but that's
not really the focus of either of these
benchmarks
we're going to talk in more detail about
how cogs and recogs compare to each
other in the core screencasts for this
unit but just briefly
Cox is the original recog's Builds on
cogs and attempts to rework some aspects
of cogs to focus on Purely semantic
phenomena whereas we believe that cogs
is testing in addition for a bunch of
incidental details of logical forms
for a quick comparison I have the input
the Sailor saw Emma here and you can see
the recogs and cogs format and in Broad
strokes The recogs Format is somewhat
simpler there are a bunch of redundant
symbols that have been removed and some
core aspects of the semantics have been
reorganized while nonetheless preserving
the meaning of the original
the recog splits work like this we have
a large train set of almost 136 000
examples and there is a Dev set of 3000
examples that are like those in train
this is a sort of IID split we're not
going to make much use of the dev split
our focus is instead on these
generalization splits this is what's so
interesting about cogs and recogns this
is 21 000 examples in 21 categories and
the name of the game here is to have
novel combinations of familiar elements
to really test to see whether models
have found compositional solutions to
the task
here are three examples of those
generalization splits they're typical of
the full set and I would say one
Hallmark of these generalization splits
is that they hardly feel like
generalization tasks for us as speakers
of the language they appear incredibly
simple but as you'll see they're very
difficult for even our best models
for example this category is subject to
object proper name the idea here is that
we'll have some names that we see in
subject position in the train set like
Lena here is the subject and then in the
generalization split we will encounter
Lena in object position and that will be
a new occurrence of Lena and the task is
to see whether the model can figure out
what role Lena plays in the semantics
for that unfamiliar input very simple
for people surprisingly difficult for
our models primitive to subject is a
similar sort of situation at train time
there are some names that just appear as
isolated elements with no syntactic con
context around them at generalization
time we have to deal with them as the
subjects of full sentences it seems
simple but it proves challenging
CP recursion is a little bit different
this is testing to see whether models
can handle novel numbers of embedded
sentences
in the train sets you get embeddings
like Emma said that Noah knew that the
cat danced and the generalization split
simply includes greater depths like Emma
said that Noah knew that Lucas saw that
the cat danced
it seems simple it hardly feels like a
generalization task to us and yet again
difficult for our models
all right that was by way of background
let's have a look at question one proper
names and their semantic roles you are
not training models for this question
this is good old-fashioned data analysis
it has two parts for task one you write
a function called get proper role names
that takes in a logical form and
extracts the list of all name role pairs
that occur in that logical form
and then for task two you write find
name roles which uses get proper name
roles to discover what roles different
proper names are playing in the various
splits that recogs contains
and I'll just give you the spoiler now
Charlie the proper name is only a theme
and train and only an agent in the
generalization splits whereas Lena is
only an agent in train and only a theme
in the generalization splits and this
observation about the data tells us a
lot about Downstream model performance
these names indeed prove very difficult
for our models to deal with
after question one I'll warn you there
is sort of a long modeling interlude
I've provided all the pieces that you
need to train your own recog's models
you don't necessarily have to do that
but I wanted to provide them so that you
could explore that as an Avenue for your
original systems so let me walk you
through this interlude the first step is
a hugging face tokenizer I'll confess to
you that my original plan was to have
this be one of the homework questions
but I found writing this hugging face
tokenizer to be so difficult and so
confusing that I decided not to burden
you with it so I'm instead offering you
this tokenizer in the hopes that you can
benefit from it and maybe modify it for
your own tasks down the line
the pi torch data set is similar this is
a data set for recogs I originally
thought it would be a homework question
but it has some fiddly details about it
that may be tentative about doing that
so instead I am just giving it to you
step three is a pre-trained recogs model
Zen train this model it is an
outstanding recogs model and the idea is
that you can just load it in and then
make use of it for your original system
you might fine tune this model or do
something else to it but you don't need
to do that for the homework question
that comes next you simply use this as a
pre-trained model and explore its
predictions
the next step is recog's loss and this
is a simple Pi torch module that helps
me make the model that Zen trained
compatible with the code that we have
for this course in general so that it's
easy for you to fine-tune the model if
you want to so that's a small detail
then we have recog's module and this is
a lightweight wrapper around Zen's model
that is again designed to help us be
compatible with the underlying
optimization code in particular that we
have in our course code base
and then finally the interlude ends at
step six with recog's module this
recog's model sorry this is the main
interface and is the only one that you
need to worry about if you're not
training models for your original system
if you're not doing that if you're
pursuing another Avenue then you can
more or less ignore one through five and
just focus on six and treat it as a
simple interface for loading Zen's model
and using it
but I'm hoping that some of you want to
dig deeper into how this model is
trained and maybe improve it and in that
case steps one through five will be
especially useful to you
so that's why they're all embedded in
The Notebook
having made it through the interlude we
now get to question two which is
exploring predictions of the model for
this question you just use Zen's trained
recogs model out of the box and what
you're doing is continuing the data
analysis that you began in question one
so you complete a function called
category assess
and the name of the game here is to
discover for yourselves that this really
good model struggles really a lot with
the proper names that are in unfamiliar
positions exactly the names that you
identified for question one and so you
can see the hypothesis behind cogs and
recog's validated here novel
combinations of these elements however
simple turn out to be challenging for
our a really good model
before proceeding I wanted to say one
thing about recog's assessment and again
we'll talk more in detail about this in
the main screencast for the unit but
just quickly the goal of recogs is
really to test for semantic
interpretation and get past some of the
incidental details of logical form so
our evaluation code is somewhat
complicated
here are three instructive examples four
recogs unlike for cogs the precise names
of bound variables do not matter so for
example these two logical forms here are
called equivalent even though the first
logical form uses the variable four and
the second logical form uses the
variable seven the idea is that since
all these variables are implicitly Bound
for recogs and cogs we don't care about
their particular identity just The
Binding relationships that they
establish and those are the same in
these two cases
here's another case the order of
conjuncts does not matter that seems
intuitive semantically and we wanted it
to be realized in our evaluation code so
dog and happy and happy and dog evaluate
to true the order of the conjuncts is
incidental
however consistency of variable names
does matter so this pair evaluates to
false because the first one uses dog and
happy
uh it has both the very variable four
for both of those predications whereas
the second one has dog of four and happy
of seven and that is semantically
distinct now we're talking presumably
about two distinct elements whereas the
first logical form is about one and so
we arrive at a conclusion that these are
semantically not equivalent
so that's three kind of cases that give
you a feel for what we're trying to do
with this evaluation which is really get
at semantic equivalence even where
logical forms vary
final question for the main part of the
homework question three switches gears
entirely this is a basic in context
learning approach and the idea here is
to just get you over the hill in terms
of using DSP as we did in homework 2 and
applying it to this new case and my
thinking here is that if I push you a
little bit to write your first DSP
program for recogs you might try more
versions of that and really make
progress
so here's the kind of logical or here's
the kind of prompt that you'll offer to
the model we've got a couple
demonstrations input and then the task
for the model is to generate a new
logical form
and the task here for you in terms of
coding is to just write a very simple
DSP program it is simple indeed as I
said My Hope Is that it's kind of
inspiring you to do more sophisticated
things maybe for your original system
I will warn you that even for our best
large language models they superficially
seem to understand what this task is
about and when you glance at The Logical
forms that they predict they often look
kind of good but then you run the
evaluation code and you get zero right
and you realize that kind of good is not
really sufficient for this task you need
to be exactly correct and these large
language models seem to struggle to be
exactly correct at this semantic parsing
task
finally question four as usual you're
doing your original system
for your original system you can do
anything you want the only constraint is
that you cannot train your system on any
examples from the generalization splits
nor can the output representations from
those examples be included in any
prompts that you use for in-context
learning the idea here is that we want
to preserve the sanctity of the
generalization splits to really get a
glimpse of whether or not systems are
generalizing in the way that we care
about
with that rule in place I thought I
would just review a few original system
ideas and remember this is not meant to
be exhaustive but rather just inspiring
about some potential Avenues so here
they are you could write a DSP program
you could do further training of our
model you could use a pre-trained model
you could train from scratch maybe you
could even write a symbolic solver and
there might be other things that you can
do let me elaborate just briefly on a
few of these options so
here if you want to further train our
model that should be very easy this
little snippet of code here loads in the
model that Zen trained and then you can
see with this here I'm doing just a
little bit of additional fine tuning of
that model on a few of the dev examples
which is fine to do because our focus is
on those gen splits and what I've done
in this snippet is expose a lot of the
different optimization parameters
because I think you'd really want to
think about how best to set up this
model to get some more juice out of the
available data from this further
training essentially
but I've will also in the notebook
offered you code that shows how easy it
is to take our starting point and modify
it to use a pre-trained model here what
I've done really is just write a T5
recogs module to load in the T5 model
and then T5 recog's model is the primary
interface and now what you've got is a
device that loads in T5 and it won't
work at all if you try to use it
directly to make predictions about the
recogs task it will actually sort of
amusingly translate your examples into
German but you could fine tune T5 so
that it can do the recogs task with the
hypothesis that the pre-training that T5
underwent is useful for helping with the
generalization splits in particular
and very similar code could be modified
so that you train from scratch by simply
loading in with hugging face code random
parameters that might have the structure
of a Burt model or something like that
hugging Pig's face makes that very easy
and you could explore different variants
essentially of training from scratch on
the recogs task
and I'll leave other options for you to
think about I'm really Keen to see what
you all do with the recogs data
and then finally for the bake off this
is straightforward there's a tsv file
that contains some test cases those are
generalization test cases you just need
to add a column prediction which can
contains your predicted logical forms
and then this final code snippet here is
what you do to write that to disk for
uploading to the gradescope auto grader
and we'll see how you all do on this
surprisingly very challenging task of
semantic interpretation